the plaintiff tom the landlord who is
seeking to evict his tenant over 850
of unpaid rent the defendant vera the
tenant who admits falling behind on rent
but says she shouldn't lose her home for
it we'll hear their stories and see what
the judge has to say
on eviction court two cents edition
a landlord can't just kick a tenant out
on a whim they need to get the ok from
the state
and the way they do that is through a
civil process known as eviction
or summary ejection a landmark study by
princeton sociologist matthew desmond
estimated that there are almost a
million evictions a year in america
that's one out of every 17 renter
households
there are many different reasons a
landlord can seek eviction
from lease violations to criminal
activity to just wanting to sell the
house
but the vast majority are over unpaid
rent
vera's story is sadly familiar these
days
she was working two jobs in retail and
food service and when the pandemic
struck
both businesses closed their doors she
managed to stay afloat with the
increased unemployment benefits from the
cares act
until they expired in july her
restaurant reopened shortly afterwards
but with drastically shortened hours
with less than half the income she used
to have she started to fall behind
and only 10 days after she failed to pay
her rent on time
she found an eviction notice taped to
her door there is an assumption that you
have to be
deep in debt to get evicted but that's
actually quite rare
according to the eviction lab the
average amount that triggers an eviction
lawsuit
is less than one month's rent if vera
can't pay her debt within a few days
she'll be summoned to court at a
specific date and time
she'll have one last chance to pay her
debts in full plus late charges and
legal fees
or the court will order a sheriff to
remove her from the property
most defendants are highly motivated to
pay the money if they can
they're probably already living in the
most affordable unit they could find
and moving into a new place means
putting down a security deposit they
almost certainly
don't have and that's assuming they get
approved
most landlords won't even consider a
tenant with an eviction
on their record this leverage creates a
temptation for landlords to use the
eviction system
as a kind of state-sponsored debt
collections agency instead of a last
resort
depending on the state filing an
eviction lawsuit can be pretty cheap
there are even automated apps that
streamline the process
and the added fees mean extra profit for
the landlord
this has led to a pattern of serial
evictions for the same tenants are
hauled into court
month after month often paying more than
extra on their rent every time they fall
behind so there's definitely potential
for landlords to abuse the system
but at least the government stepped in
this year to put a hold on evictions
during the coveted crisis yes the cdc
announced a federal moratorium on
evictions until at least
the end of the year because you know
it's hard to quarantine without a home
but there are some conditions it only
applies to tenants making less than a
hundred grand a year
and the tenant must declare in writing
three things
that they experienced a loss of income
from kovit that they have nowhere else
to go
and that they tried their best to find
financial assistance
the moratorium doesn't mean that vera's
rent is forgiven
only that she can't be removed from the
premises until 2021.
her landlord is still free to bring her
to court before then
where he can contest her claims change
his pretext
to something not covered by the
moratorium like lease violations or
just hope the tenant hasn't heard about
the moratorium and will leave on our own
tom the landlord has opted to challenge
vera's declaration
which may sound cold-hearted but let's
take a closer look at his side of the
story
ten years ago after an injury left tom
unable to keep working as a plumber
he decided to use his savings as a down
payment on two rental properties and
become
a full-time landlord unfortunately the
job turned out to be a bit harder than
he anticipated
like many mom and pop real estate
investors the rent
tom collects from his tenants barely
covers his mortgage's property taxes
upkeep and personal living expenses but
he figures that the
increase in home values will at least
allow him to sell the properties in 20
years for enough to retire on
and then along came kovid landlord
associations across the country are
mounting
legal challenges to the cdc's moratorium
arguing that it essentially forces
property owners
to subsidize their tenant's housing the
cares act provided
some relief for owners allowing them to
defer their mortgage payments for
six to 12 months without incurring late
fees but like the tenants
those debts aren't forgiven when the
forbearance period ends
tom will have to figure out how to pay
everything he owes or
risk losing his properties tom's done
the math and he just can't afford to
rack up
months of mortgage debt without any
rental income
as bad as he might feel for vera he
doesn't think he should be the one to
pay for her problems
so his lawyer makes the argument that
vera hasn't adequately searched for
rental assistance programs
and therefore doesn't qualify for the
moratorium
we'd like to say that vera brought
evidence of her applications to numerous
government housing grants that had
already run dry
and that the judge summarily dismissed
the eviction lawsuit
case closed but let's get real the
majority of people who find themselves
in this situation don't have the time or
information to mount a thorough defense
they can afford to bring lawyers with
them many aren't even aware of their
rights
and most don't show up to court at all
meaning
the landlord wins by default and even
though mom and pop landlords like tom
are getting hit hard by the pandemic
reports suggest that the majority of
eviction lawsuits are actually filed by
large
corporate landlords owned by investment
firms and hedge funds
that are better able to weather the
storm these firms have been
somewhat restrained by the moratorium
but they're already preparing suits to
evict
thousands of tenants as soon as the
clock runs out
i suppose we could just blame the
pandemic but unfortunately the eviction
crisis began
well before covid came along according
to the bureau of labor statistics
hourly wages have increased only 5 to 25
over the last couple decades while the
cost of renting
has skyrocketed by 70
while the number of rental units in
america has increased by 10.9 million
the number of units for 600 or less in
inflation-adjusted dollars
has decreased by 4 million essentially
all our new units are for high-income
renters while
low-income renters have vastly fewer
options to choose from
today the majority of renters who make
less than 30k a year
are spending over half their income on
rent
so if we're looking for root causes of
america's eviction epidemic
a lot of the blame goes to our lack of
affordable housing
this is no easy problem to fix with
congress unable to agree on how to
address it
and local communities opposed to any
low-income development in their
neighborhoods
it's a cold fact of capitalism that real
estate developers
can make more money building homes for
rich people than poor people
so that's what they'll continue to do
but the costs
get shifted to the public states spend
money
processing eviction suits landlords have
to find new tenants
cities have to expand social services
and homeless facilities and of course
families are losing their homes and with
them their ability to find
work all over debts that are usually
less than a thousand dollars
as with most systemic problems looking
for blame
is less productive than looking for
solutions as clemson professor
elora raymond put it is it the tenant's
fault is it the landlord's fault
i think it doesn't really matter because
this doesn't work
and that's our two cents
[Music]
if you're caught in a legal jam because
of unpaid rent or debts
there are organizations that can help
check out our video guide to dealing
with debt collectors to learn more